hey guys what - can four three four a
week actually at the marketing festival
in the South of France what you're about
to see is the correlation of three days
jammed up highlight-reel
hope you enjoy it you got your
perspective Gary your most valuable
creative bless you I would go with
self-awareness I think that we need to
put that word on a much bigger cultural
pedestal really getting to a place where
you understand yourself and I would say
self-awareness needs to be kind of like
oxygen it's a 24/7 thing when you're 22
and you're wide eyed and bushy tailed
there's something that you really want
and and then at 26 you fall in love and
you want a different like you've got to
really check that at all times like what
are you up to is it about currency is it
about legacy is about fulfilment
work-life balance like I'm sure
everybody here has gone through maybe
one cycle of going all-in but then
looking for more balance and then going
back all-in and so I think you've got to
know what you're good at
I mean I the reality is you know I
watched so many people try to fix their
shortcomings and I can and we're I just
wish that they would triple down on
their super strengths where I think
would just be far better for them
[Music]
this deep fake thing really is
fascinating
if you think about a eyes advancement
like I'm like wow we're talking about a
half decade from now where this shit's
gonna be perfect and now what are we
just only in a place where like like you
could you know it's so funny the
openness of the internet was something I
understood I think we're gonna see a big
like I almost feel like I'm just gonna
be live streaming at all times to prove
it's me and what I have to say like I
actually everybody thinks it's gonna
close I even just started saying the
closeness my counter move to the
closeness is complete on this yeah I
mean there's if I stream all every
minute of my life
there should be no debate if I ever said
it cuz a document that if I did or did
it I can prove that it in you've been
watching at all times some Truman Show
[ __ ] what's your take on that well I
mean we've spent this time we've like I
want to say we I mean all of us we've
all spent this era of like being used to
idea like oh it's on video it happened
right
and so like eyewitness footage I mean
that's the thing that scares me
especially from international places
where we don't we don't actually have a
window in necessarily because there's
not free press and like now we're gonna
be having we're have this new dynamic
that's coming in where we have to
evaluate everything on this new level
yeah and we're like not the world is not
ready for them no because what as you're
as you know that means people are just
gonna go into the prejudices by having
the ability to say deep fake now you can
basically say that didn't happen right
like this horrific [ __ ] of the
police and Phoenix if you want to be on
the side of the racism you can just say
that's a [ __ ] video yeah that
[ __ ] hurts
I agree listen this is we're there
listen there's a complete restructuring
of our society in our faces right now
nationalism on the on the rise deep to
your point I mean that's a that's a
great way to put it
we've lived for a hundred years on the
assumption of if it's on film it's true
yeah and we were about to enter the era
of that not being true
[Music]
I often talk about being a shield to
give them courage I'm very proud that
for especially for a lot of immigrant
kids or a lot of people like I'm getting
I'm giving them permission I'm creating
oh I'm so comfortable with judgment
against me
then I'm giving them room to try
something and if it fails they could say
well Gera you know I want to take the
blame for them to give them the step my
observation from the far is you do that
for a lot of people and I think that is
an incredible gift to give when I say
that when I bring that up does that make
sense to you do you understand what I'm
saying absolutely heard that because
some Gary I always say that the single
best moment of my life and by the way
this wasn't a single moment it was a
gradual realization but the best moment
of my life was the day that I realized I
no longer give a damn what anybody
thinks
go figure I thought it's the only way to
live your life and I especially
communicate that message to women
because from the moment were born as
women everything around us conspires to
make us feel insecure about actually
everything to do with us you know the
infrastructure way we look the way we
talk the way we dress them yeah life
skills do this my skills dip than that
women spend the rest of our lives came
back from that and some of us never do
I'm sorry I want a shortcut that process
for every woman but also to your point
for everybody who is worried about what
other people think because I'm choosy
which is everybody which is everybody
but do anything because that's the worst
way to me I think I also observe this
again because we don't know each other
that well I observe this from you as
well which I really appreciate in a
times when people have been a dinner
table your name gets brought up you know
this is what happens to me too and I go
be careful I'm like if you watch her
interact and I'm proud of this as well
one thing that's amazing that I think
you do extremely well is not giving a
[ __ ] what anybody thinks does not me or
mean you do not hear other people oh no
no no this is not no no you're right I
mean don't do it down while the people's
think in a good way you know that's
right you live your life and work your
work according to your values I don't
want to even you do a really good job of
bringing awareness to things to put
pressure or to bring conversation and I
have watched you bring awareness is
something hey this is not except tweet I
don't like this or what star take on
this or whatever it may be
I've watched people that are on the
receiving end of that 99% of time not
answer
of the left of the left one percent 0.9
percent of defend with [ __ ]
yeah but occasionally I've seen in that
point one percent remaining somebody
giving clarity context and you were
extremely quick to also here in and this
is not you rallying them people rallying
a mob it pisses me off
I've watched you molten I do the same
thing like sometimes people say
something to me friend of my Ted the
other day said hey I don't like your
definition of an entrepreneur by nature
you're not one I watched the video and
I'm like he's right I worked for my dad
and this definition of never working for
anybody is not a good definition I need
to clarify and I'm a little worried
about like you know I'm trying to
protect over entrepreneurship so in that
I think you know I could get excited
sometimes and you're throwing out
headlines and it was an incredible
back-and-forth where and I've seen that
from you and that for me is why I so
desperately wanted you here today it's
why for me I adamantly support a lot of
what you do talk about that like not
giving a [ __ ] but actually having the
capacity to hear when somebody has a
counterpoint that may penetrate your
psyche as you're going through the
conversation but well I think you know
all I'd say to that Gary is that when
you actually don't kill other people
think that free as you are to just hear
people thrill yeah as opposed to
worrying all the time throughout what
other people think and therefore having
that lens obscure the truth of something
they should be looking at different my
god more than I thought it would
dude it's just fun you don't even like
so that just gave me this look
goosebumps you know why having start I
wanted the first 10 this Harry who runs
time she runs tom's of Maine rx
she's not doing a podcast with yes yes
we do by this week
I'm Jim Stengel and my mission in life
is to help brands find the purpose and
activated earlier in my life I was the
Procter & Gamble chief marketing officer
looking out over hundreds of brands
around
you may not know it but the CMOS of all
of your favorite brands are really
trying to bring purpose to life in their
brands and on this show you're gonna
learn their lessons how they delve into
it and you're also gonna learn about the
habits and practices and rituals of
these remarkable people in how they work
and how they play and how they thrive
right here on the CMO podcast
[Music]
a lot of people don't want to know the
exact road right they want to know you
have conference ready that another so
you're saying I got a friend parents but
then it's not the same rat than the same
conversation or Senkaku parents
so what if you don't have that support
to make that confidence where so
everybody's gonna have different
situations and different serendipities
so it's not just my parents like I got
self-esteem injected than my parent from
my mom
which is a huge variable which is why I
put her on the huge pedestal to your
point not everybody gets that somebody
may get that later from their spouse I
would argue if my dad was here he would
tell you that any progression in his
self-confidence came when I came into
his life and started making him feel
like he did something because he grew up
under a mom who did it give him
confidence so at the same token to your
point when I'm saying [ __ ] your parents
I'm saying it's more of a way to break
through to kids to say look you need to
lean into your truth you need to you
know you need to have empathy for why
your parents are giving you the advice
but the reality is this is gonna be your
life and you're gonna have to deal with
the ramifications so yeah by the way by
the way even though my mom or somebody
else who's lucky enough to have a mom
and still enormous amounts of
self-esteem into them doesn't mean that
same mom may not have an ideological
point of view on you being a doctor so
they're not self one or the other
they're kind of like carved out separate
things and back to the point of all of
this I mean I think one of the biggest
things that I'm really excited about
clarifying in the next half decade is
look I don't think I'm right about
anything I think that I'm right for me I
read a lot of feedback and these are
observations from one man's point of
view and then you need to take it and
understand what to do with it one of the
things I'm most passionate about right
now is there's a lot of cultures
especially in Asia and India and other
places we're not listening to your
parents is a massive disrespect massive
problem it's a it's it's it's being
disobedient the amount of times that
I've seen the word not behaving and
being disobedient and it's been
unbelievable in the last two three
months they're like Gary you don't stand
like I can't do that like that is just
like a death blow and I'm like you don't
understand that's exactly what you need
to do because here's the alternative
you're gonna be 39 years old walking to
your parents [ __ ] living room for
some nice tea and tell them to go [ __ ]
themselves and never talk to them again
I'm trying to save relationships by
telling people to fight their parents
now because what always happens in this
scenario is it dies later right then
they marry somebody that spouse loves
them and is like don't let your parents
control your life it becomes all [ __ ]
up with the mother-in-law and the
sister-in-law in the brother leg you
know right like [ __ ]
what's way better is called like go do
what you want to do but then deal with
the ramifications the the other shoe in
my conversation of go do what you want
is if you go on and fail you have to
give the point to the parents that's the
part that nobody wants to hear of like
go [ __ ] your parents is super fun when
your parents want you to do something
but you didn't have self awareness and
you just wanted to be like me and you
started a [ __ ] startup company and
you fail you have to be okay with going
back and Nan this was saying your
parents right because you never wanted
to be a doctor but acknowledging you
lost like delusion doesn't work it leads
to depression
thanks Jimmy wish you nothing but the
best bro sure for you all the time
thank you guys thank you bye bye
yeah hey guys that was just me on the
gym room show Rome is burning one of the
iconic sports personalities of all time
had a I was on this show like three
years ago just like this like outside I
can like he loved it it was the first
time I was on this show we had dinner in
LA once or twice I just I liked him
it was very gracious to give me a
platform today to talk about our tops
partnership if you're watching this
video or listening to it if you don't
know top series to Gary Vee
- Gary B's top entrepreneurs in baseball
one of the most exciting things I've
ever done I highly highly recommend you
go out to your local hobby store tops
calm or Walmart Target and buy a couple
of packs let me know if you pull the
Gary Vee cards you could probably tell
by my tone I'm like literally one of
like the great [ __ ] things I've ever
done
[Music]
[Applause]
we're 2020 challenge or coming up with
the campaign that needs to launch by
September on Alexa run for 18 months
it's on Alexa to avoid strategy and AWS
campaign with creative technology it's
not just a skill for technologies 360
save the world
similar to global citizen last year
bring as much awareness to it to
actually save the world is this feasible
cannon launched will people care that
was my thing this morning because they
were telling me their idea I said no
one's gonna use this you can say that
too because I think that if they launch
an idea that solves the problem but is
that engaging or encouraging for people
to actually not just use once but
repeatedly engage with and care about
well then that means it's not solving
the problem exactly
it's ambition its albatross today were
arguing with me but the consumable
speaking I said if you're gonna you
might win the judges might like your
idea but you're not gonna win if it
doesn't actually launch and is it you so
go to market strategy is important as
well
trophies aren't fun when your business
sucks
have you guys spent any time on trying
to tackle the fact that it's become a
political issue so I think the biggest
issue like like when I do these things I
actually want to try to do something
about it I'm not just here for like the
sake of a competition I think the
biggest issue with climate is not you
know collecting data
it's that half the world has decided
it's not an issue because the politics
of that country or that side of the
country has decided has there been
anything for you to have debated that
because I think one of the things that
you might you know great so you're gonna
have a massively tiny percentage of the
most extreme social liberal people in
each Society get so compelled that
they're gonna do the actual work but
that's gonna be a very very very small
group and I'm wondering has there been
any discussion of that truth amongst you
and has there been any comms planning or
any debating amongst you to like not how
we're gonna convince people that the
Paris Accord matters or climate matters
but maybe galvanize the 50% that do that
or maybe like I believe in it very
heavily I will never do this not because
I don't believe but because I don't like
to do that I don't want to do work and
so I'd rather you know one tough thing
with a lot of extremely social liberal
people is a lot of them are also a
fluent and they want to use money
instead of doing so for example I want
to save the world just like any good
person but I want to use my money to do
that or influence not actually do work
so for example playing that out one of
the things that we may recognize your is
this may skew very young as activism and
doing the right thing has become cool
younger name you know 18 year old me did
not have as much money but did want to
be cool so I would think a lot about
communication here of getting people
that will actually do it how do we make
this a status symbol
see where I'm going could really give
you a chance of making this actually
happen because the biggest issue with
things like this is you're telling us
through communication that you should be
doing this and immediately how humans
actually work is [ __ ] you my mom has
cancer the [ __ ] are you telling me to
take pictures of the [ __ ] world
that's what we're losing on big issues
doesn't work that's why we have
nationalism and extreme rightness
growing we did a lot of this for 15
years and nobody liked it and then we
have them so this is no shot unless
you're thoughtful about either building
status in the youth and that male
they'll do the work because everybody
else who believes in it is to a plinth
and doesn't want to do work and
everybody else who believes in it but as
an affluent and as the older is just
trying to make ends meet very important
this is why all these things die
we're not empathetic in our little
meeting here
yeah so think about that I think that
will help you have a you know you see
where I'm going with that I think it's a
good it's good perspective you probably
could tell by the way something way I'm
articulating it I spend a lot of time
thinking about that a lot of that
because I want so many things to happen
in the world
but most of my friends that see it the
same way they go into pontificating and
scolding instead of actually trying to
get it done that's the danger and this
requires work 10 photos 1500 photos you
know
badges within an ecosystem that doesn't
mean anything [ __ ] means nothing
right so I would how are you gonna make
that connection point that's super
important to me let me give you a left
let me give you a left-field thing how
do we make a hoodie and then put it on a
bunch of rappers and soccer players and
other things that matter and then people
find out actually the only way you can
get that hoodie is if you use this app
and get to the badge level you gotta
make the hoodie cool having 50 bat point
badge to your point earlier we're gonna
incentivize with the Amazon actions I do
think that works I like where you want
with that
my intuition though is monetary value
won't be enough on such an altruistic
thing but having a limited edition
hoodie that everybody thinks is you know
so I'm going think people have to think
more you know I always dream about like
you know people want to use Beyonce and
and all these people are like you know I
would probably have Beyonce wears
something crazy when she makes the
announcement make it about that thing
like what you're wearing which is rad
and then hope everybody wants it and
then we tell the world oh you want that
here's how see where I'm going
because this out of all of them has a
lot of friction you're asking people to
do a lot you're relying on incentives
and badges we need those things to mean
something first otherwise nobody does
anything fortnight meant something first
then you can do gamification not the
other way around
and you don't need to write like to me
with only ten minutes I take you know
it's funny I don't come here to check a
box or cuz I like Michelle I want to
really bring value so like what I'm
trying to do here I think I did right
which is I'm listening then I'm like
okay it's this now you can go back and
that's what you need to work on that's
all fine and dandy but like you know you
know it's like it's the biggest problem
on social issues we're we're trying to
convince people to change their mind who
are worried about making ends meet you
think somebody who's making it you know
you know entry-level salaries cares
about the Paris Accord they do not its
third generation wealthy people we
understand or the youth but the youth
will change its mind fast so we have to
make it cool status got it
that's why I believe companies have the
biggest chance to change the world
because you're wearing that polo for a
reason you're trying to communicate
that's what fashion has right this is my
argument on plastic bottles they keep
telling people as long as possible but
as long as Fiji and smart water is
status you're not changing jack-shit
status got it cool awesome thank you
nice to meet you
[Music]
[Music]
so the plastic-like art director
copywriter team models since you guys
have your crazy wild wild west what's up
with the client how do you feel about
you know the copywriter and the art
director working together we love it
work yeah we have that certain the one
thing that we have is every account and
we don't have this everywhere all the
way yet because we're just rolling south
but we're really close now every account
has three full-time creatives 100%
dedicated to the logo even when it's a
five hundred thousand dollar fee account
and that person is a copy person a
design person and then a what we call a
shreditor she or he is doing film and
post-production as one person kind of
what Darach does for me and and again as
you can imagine that production value
when you're making five thousand pieces
of content is not necessarily the film's
that you know it's it's it's native it's
the [ __ ] that you actually like when
you're consuming content and some of it
can be very high production value and we
just chop a bunch down it's some of it
could be grab your iPhone make this
video on the counter and post it so they
are there and then above them are teams
art and copy CDs and you know what
what's happening is that the core
creator team is very allocated a hundred
percent on one account as you go up
those teams are spread out more but
they're all making I mean it's the thing
I put the most pressure on Adam and Mike
about is I need you on the way to work
write a tweet for Budweiser a rolling
rock to set the tone that if RG CDs are
making this is a making culture you have
people that start hitting gcd level that
never make a single thing for 7/10 make
a single thing so like one thing that I
would love for all of you to do is start
a little side hustle of trying to sell
something on Shopify and Amazon and then
be the marketer of that like by like 50
t-shirts put it on Shopify but then go
do ads on Instagram snap you know buy a
pre-roll you know podcast ad from a
small podcast and write the copy for the
read be a practitioner that's why I walk
with such audacity
my confidence is I know nobody here does
you know like like they like they'll get
into a debate I'm like you're talking
about an mmm and you're talking about
oopss you're talking about
subjectiveness I'm talking about truth
so it's not it's always a very exciting
conversation to get into a debate with
somebody from the industry because
they're living within the industry not
what we're supposed to be doing it's
ideology versus practicality ideology
always loses unless you start making it
practical everybody wants everybody else
to change the world so then you can only
do it by doing that's what you have to
have to provide know why everybody
everybody knows why everybody's got
[ __ ] ideas you have to
[Music]
so let's let's zoom out for just a
moment because we're also still even
just focus out of campaign mind seconds
we're still just talking about marketing
but the human on the other side is
experiencing things with e-commerce in
retail they're calling a call center
they're dealing with a chatbot there's
all this stuff
yup that they're touching and I guess my
question is can we aspire to a world
where more of those things are actually
fueled by the same intelligence and
approach or is it something that's too
ambitious to tie marketing and customer
experience together and really connect
the dots around you it's gonna be
required it's you know that's the beauty
of innovation and truth ultimately it
wins it didn't matter what all the
people with the medallions on their
taxis thought about uber in New York it
happened it didn't matter what all the
networks thought about Netflix it
happened it didn't matter what Walmart
thought about Amazon it happened what we
plan on being one of the people in this
industry of doing and many others I hope
follow and many of the people here I
come here not to recruit to the
pontificate I come to inspire people to
build their own independent shops so
they can do the work that they want to
be doing versus what they have to be
doing that's how we'll change the
industry and that's gonna happen with me
or not I may have a chance to buy the
New York Jets next year and then I'll
move on my merry way but the realities
that will be a requirement for this
industry and when you talk about the
consumer guys how many normal people
like even though this week is happening
zero normal any consumers have no idea
of this world the things we've talked
about like they just live on brand is my
favorite thing Gary that's off-brand I'd
like you beside you the brand manager of
the opinion of one decide what's on
brand because you interpreted a sentence
which a copywriter wrote as the brand
what it stands for and you've decided
this is an aspirational living for the
modern man get the [ __ ] out of here so I
apologize but yes all of this is gonna
matter and I will say this much of what
I pontificate around volume of creative
BM empathetic creating 30-40 meaningful
cohorts to attack not one
what is 18 to 35 are you kidding me you
know the reason we have so many issues
with diversity and gender issues in
creative is because we have one
30-second spot what are you gonna put
everybody in it like it's crazy we need
a complete shift in our mindset of
creative we need to stop demonizing
quantity in this industry quantity does
not come expensive quality it's an
excuse for those who do not want to do
and so we have a lot of things to work
on Gary
what is your favorite work empathy I
think that empathy is something that you
know obviously I've started a wine brand
somebody showed me a world word cloud
three years ago and everybody thinks I'm
hustle and [ __ ] and all this and sure
enough in my word cloud analyzed every
word for me empathy kindness gratitude
patience I understand how I manifest in
my DNA on stage but the way I Drive what
I do day to day internally and results
is a hundred percent predicated empathy
first for my employees second for my
clients customers third for my clients
that is a very different framework than
everybody else rolling around here which
is why we will win in the end
I love with two minutes okay I'm gonna
go try to go that's fear I think for me
because I was an immigrant because I had
bad grades my whole life I was losing
that by the time I was a grown up losing
and fear didn't mean anything to me
so I got lucky in so much adversity as a
child I think if you haven't had that or
even if you had that you still fear it
because of the way your parents judged
you know you have to practice you know
it's you know like you have to practice
doing things that you are scared of it's
very true it's like when people talk to
me about fear it feels so heavy I'm like
it's like swimming or kissing a boy you
were scared of that when you were young
until you did it and then you were being
hit before talking to me right but then
practice gets you there
so you have to practice things that feel
scary and then you'll get more used to
them it's the truth it's just the truth
[Music]
they tell me yes just had a very quick
Harriet but I gather you've got a little
bit of a different tank on the market a
little bit of a different take yes I
think that that we need a more
progressive conversation on volume of
creative that the industry needs to
start not demonizing quantity okay this
notion that quality is given up when you
do a quantity of creative is a huge
misnomer and something that I think
would really benefit the industry and
most of all the brands most brands can't
make relevant creative because they're
not making enough creative to hit the
many different cohorts they need to be
talking to and so they end up making one
vanilla piece of video don't speak so
let's just get this done and Donna
you're in your great ways I'm sorry
they're not making enough creative to
hit all the cohorts so just making one
you know we we are - we are - infatuated
with reach and not enough around
relevance and if you don't make 7400
3000 pieces of meaningful content you
can never create actual relevance okay
but if you go walk the streets right now
one of the worst words in the creative
community is volume and quantity that's
right and that needs to be cut we need
to have a more thoughtful conversation
around yeah they are yeah and so yeah
funnily enough there was a net farm
above HBO session yesterday where they
were saying oh how can you increase your
output without sort of losing the secret
source of HBO in a podium and how can
you do that without sacrifice now now
like that in the form of a one-hour
drama is a far more interesting debate
than trying to communicate a toothpaste
or a shampoo or soda pop to the end
consumer right you know if I'm trying to
sell know what what what we know about
long-form video the theater movies
television is some shows are not meant
for everybody we have four people here
and that's okay that's meanwhile we have
this audacious conversation that this
30-second spots supposed to make
everybody yeah inspire to buy
HBO does do a lot of creative yeah they
have many different shows if HBO was a
creative agency they would have one show
I would say the inflection points for me
have been the hiring or acquisitions
like peer Wow and Ryan and Mary Cade
they've just been people our inflection
point has just been people it's when
it's when I've made good decisions
instead of bad decisions of people who I
can dance with for a long period of time
and and it's unbelievable to me how much
of the variable is casting I think about
business more and more every day like I
think about sports right the when the
Knicks had Clyde Frazier and Willis Reed
and Earl the Pearl Monroe they won
championships when they have the bums
that have been wearing the jerseys for
the last 25 years they don't and so a
lot of people talk about teams as being
good and not good it's the casting
within it you know we have a lot of the
casting you know there's not it's been
it's been the human decision-making it's
been the 17 to 44 people that have
disproportionately impacted the business
and every time I made that write call
and by the way every time I made the
wrong call it's slowing down opportunity
and I think it's a hum to me it's very
heavily predicated people
[Music]
guys if you like the amount of you that
are not subscribed to this channel is
devastating please subscribe and leave a
comment let me know how you like the
3-day mashup we're always listening
[Music]